le code on va prendre monsieur machin
allez hop
oui bonjour
dites donc c'est encore votre chien qui
a fait caca dans le dans l'entrée là
tout le monde dit que c'est le vôtre
vous nettoyez où on le fait
[Musique]
bah ouvrez on va on va nettoyer mais bon
faites attention quand même
merci
[Musique]
et hop allô oui on est en train de faire
des essais est-ce que vous m'entendez
essayez voir d'appuyer sur le bouton
pour ouvrir la porte
[Musique]
merci
il fait froid
ouais
allô oui bonjour madame c'est moule 30 à
l'appareil livraison de moules
marinières à domicile
ah bon mais moi je vous ai pas commandé
des moules pardon je vous ai pas
commander des moules en plus c'est super
lourd pensez-vous il y en a pour cette
d'accord c'est bien gentil madame
[Musique]
oui bonjour c'est pour qui veut gagner
des millions
comment dit-on 7 et 3 fontons ou c'était
trois fonds
c'était un piège
on peut pas faire gagner des millions
comme ça
[Musique]